[Music]
you and i both have friends all over the
spectrum i got friends who are
psychiatrists who i will go have dinner
and i'll just say you are destroying
earth and they'll say you're an idiot
right
how do you stay in relationship with
folks who have
same credentials all both also see
patients
and see the world a little bit
differently how do you how do you stay
in relationship with folks like that how
do you stay in community with people
like that
yeah so for for me it's this way one
i know what i'm called to do like i i
think this helps a lot i think when you
know
uh you're wise big you're responsible
for this
but not for this yep then that helps so
for me i know i'm responsible for three
big things
loving god which a sense essentially
means for i just want to clarify for me
that means
having an intimate relationship with him
i know he hears me i know
how how uh just what a good dad he is
and and also loving somebody i know his
dreams i know his desires i know what he
wants me to do i'm being obedient i'm
having this
i'm being trustworthy with him so i'm
building a deep interrelation with him
so i'm loving god
loving people and i'm trying to make
earth a heavenly place those are the
three things i believe i've called to do
gotcha
and so with that loving people means
it's not me
you know forcing them to do anything
it's not me trying to push my political
opinion on them or my diet
health opinion or anything else it's
seeing them where they're at
and trying to you know there's a great
book by tim keller i love it's the
meaning of marriage
and our job as spouses is to make each
other holy
and you don't do that by forcing it you
do that by living a life yourself you do
that by encouraging people you do that
by
finding the greatness in them and
supporting and calling out and saying
doing a combination of i call it this is
i believe what
leadership is it's nourishing somebody
loving somebody and then
challenging them holding them to ins and
showing them
what they're capable of and the ultimate
thing that god's called them to do
in that order right exactly which i love
yeah and so and so what i try and do if
i'm in that sort of relationship it's
hey paul man i love that you're doing
this i love you doing this by the way i
saw this interview man you were so well
like i'm encouraging them and i'm and
this isn't inauthentic
and so i'm calling out what you are
great at and also but you know what
i really think you should consider
looking into this because i think this
is a little off
i had this personal experience where i
saw this
but hey just want to let you know still
hey i love you i just i love what you're
up to
so you know what i'm saying it's just
sort of like and it's also a love
sandwich there too
yeah of course but that's so so i think
too and because we're in a
difficult world today with the heated
political tension where it's really easy
for me to see somebody and think
it's easy for me to become resentful
yeah really easy for
i think most people to today especially
when we're talking politics in these
different things
but i think i got to realize they're
they're not called and i'm not called to
make people believe like
like i i believe i'm called to just
nourish and challenge them serve other
people yeah
yeah i have come to
love having a collection of friends
who are also experts who i disagree with
i i've come to just love that um
because if i just circle surround myself
with the same books
that i've read the same five times and
the same perspectives
i know one thing i know i'm just gonna
sit where i'm at right
and there'll be no there'll be no growth
there'll be no movement that we know
anything and i
end up just sitting still right and it
becomes i've just become a boring lazy
person
and so i i've come to love that and what
i'm trying to do is to get outside my
head and say
is there a secret sauce to that am i
just built weird because i love
disagreeing with people in in lovely fun
ways over meals
i'd never i just don't understand
fighting but i do love
healthy discussion and i just makes my
my life more rich
um but i love to hear that from you too
well i love this because there's a book
and uh a person who actually mentioned
me years ago his name was skip moen and
he has his phd in hebrew and not just
hebrews the hebrew of
genesis and so he wrote a book and it's
really good it really goes through the
hebrew perspective
of christianity in the war in a world
view it's a little book about world view
and he really looks and he said listen
the western world view is all about
black and white
we're going to debate and essentially
you're my enemy here in western world
view what was brought up by the greeks
and especially the romans
and sort of this thing where it's like
you're right or wrong everything is
black and white in that way
versus the eastern viewpoint and really
more of jesus viewpoint
or what practice even in the east today
is hey listen we're gonna have a
conversation today we don't have to
completely agree with each other
we're called to love and support each
other but we we can have a
disagreement and and argue and that's
normal in fact
you know when you read up in the new
testament read all about rabbis rabbis
were constantly
that's the part of the joy right that's
right yeah and it was over meals as
you're saying and so i think i think
remembering that it's not about being
today it's all about are you right or
are you wrong who wins and losses right
yeah and and today
it's it's like nobody we've all heard
this quote you've probably said it on
your show
nobody wins an argument right and so i
think keeping that in mind that it's not
about winning or losing
it's about uh you know loving god loving
people making earth a heavenly place
what
what can you do to help do that and
that's what and even in business right
now like we're so conscious of that
healing the planet helping heal people
um
you know i think uh again those are the
things i think that i just constantly
try and keep top of mind love it dude